hi everyone welcome to the castle
lecture it's so wonderful to see so many
of you here before I introduce our
speaker today Kathleen Thelen I want to
tell you a little bit about this Castle
lecture series these are the signature
speaker series of the ethics politics
and economics major at Yale University
these lectures aim to promote our
awareness of the ethical challenges and
complexities of societies and they're
also meant to Foster robust dialogue
about the moral foundations of society
and government the series was
established in 1988 when Mr castle made
a generous gift to Yale in honor of his
ancestor Reverend James Pont who founded
the collegate school of Connecticut in
1701 this name may be familiar because
this a is school then became renamed
after its um main benefactor yel
University so we're grateful to Mr CLE
and his family for the contribution to
epan and to yel college more generally
our speaker today is Kathleen Thelen for
professor of political science at MIT
her work focuses on the origins and
evolution of political Economic
Institutions in Rich democracies and
she's the author among other of
varieties of liberalization and the New
Politics of social solidarity how
institutions evolve and she's coeditor
of American political economy politics
markets and power during her career she
has received many awards for her
insightful work and because of time
constraints I'm not going to go through
the whole list I'm just going to mention
a few of the most recent ones she was
awarded the Aaron wildavsky enduring
contribution prize the Michael Andress
research prize the barington Moore book
prize the goodro Wilson Foundation Award
of the apsr among many others she holds
honorary degrees at the Free University
of Amsterdam LSC the European University
Institute in Florence and the University
of
Copenhagen Professor Thelen has served
as president of the American Political
Science Association she has also been
chair of the council for European and
studies and the president of the society
for the advancement of socio economics
she was awarded sorry she was elected to
the American Academy of Arts and
Sciences and to the Berlin Brandenburg
Academy of
Sciences finally she's a key figure in
the consortion of American political
economy a recent network of Scholars
that examin the United States
distinctive mix of capitalism and
democracy and fitting with the
Consortium mission in today's talk we're
going to hear about American retail
capitalism and the origins of the Amazon
economy the format of this lecture will
be that Professor Thelen will speak for
about 50 minutes and then we're going to
open up for questions and H from the
audience so please join me in welcoming
Professor
[Music]
Thelen so I want to first uh Begin by
saying that this is a tremendous honor
to have been asked to to deliver the
castle lecture uh I want to thank my
Yale colleagues for this uh for the
invitation um I want to take uh thank
John castle and his family in absentia
unfortunately uh for the um for
sponsoring and supporting this whole
series um and all of you for for coming
today to to listen so uh I became
interested in uh American retail
capitalism as I was watching this kind
of ferocious
uh ambitious retail entrepreneur who was
engaged in a really aggressive strategy
of Relentless expansion offering
convenient atome shopping for a kind of
ever widening uh range of products while
also maintaining very low prices uh
because of the huge sales volume that
this was generating so this company's
success uh of course uh provoked
antipathy among the small independent
Merchants who really couldn't match the
the sort of large inventory and
especially low cost of this retail giant
you also had critics complaining that
this company's profits were being
underwritten by taxpayers because of the
central role that the US postal system
was playing in delivering these Goods to
customers meanwhile the firm's employees
uh virtually all of them of course un
unionized were bearing the brunt of this
really monotonous but also kind of
frantic paced uh work uh in
state-of-the-art warehouses deploying
the the latest uh
Technologies uh suppliers to this
company felt squeezed uh and trapped in
a relationship of unequal dependence
right they were relying on this Outlet
to get their goods to their customers uh
but customers well customers were
smitten because now they had the luxury
of shopping from home uh choosing from
this really wide selection of every
imaginable product all at uh unbeatable
prices with money back guarantees uh and
special perks for loyal customers uh and
everything delivered right to their door
uh and if you think that I'm talking
about Amazon uh you would actually be
wrong uh because the company that I'm
describing is actually Sears and robu CA
1908 so it was these parallels between
the business strategies of Amazon today
uh and those of Sears over a century ago
that really sparked my interest in uh
retail capitalism in the United States
okay so I'm a comparativist um I'm a
europeanist uh but the American case is
really important uh for students of the
political economy of the rich
democracies like myself because the US
is really seen as a kind of
quintessential uh consumer Society
consumption and by extension retailing
uh is just widely recognized as
absolutely critical to sustaining this
country's uh demand-driven uh growth
model so it turns out that retailing
distribution is a substantively very
important sector across really all the
rich democracies uh it accounts for
between uh 10 and 15% of jobs across
really all the oecd countries which
actually puts it uh very close to
manufacturing it's even higher uh in the
United States as you see in 2003 three
uh the number of Americans working in
retail actually surpassed the number
working in factories and in the last
couple of decades uh retail really past
manufacturing is kind of the leading uh
force in economic growth uh in the
United States so in terms of employment
large discount retailers specifically uh
are by really big margins uh the biggest
uh Employers in the United States uh and
big retailers as you see here really
just don't play the same sort of central
role in employment in other countries
and even though European retailing has
been kind of moving toward the American
model uh on some Dimensions I think it's
fair to say that the US really still
stands out uh in some important
ways first off uh if as you see in this
figure as I hope you can see uh the US
just has way more retail space uh per
capita than Europe um and that's a
function of course of these huge uh
shopping centers that you find in most
American suburbs what you see on the
right here is the famous Mall of America
in Minnesota which has over 500 stores
uh and over 20,000 parking spots uh but
the outsized presence of these retailers
is also a function of these big box
discount retailers like Target uh and
Walmart uh that are really ubiquitous in
the United States according to Forbes um
90% of Americans actually live within 15
minutes of a of a Walmart and of course
these places are basically always open
so one of the biggest differences to
Europe is that shopping hours are simply
far more regulated uh in most European
countries and then last but not least
these huge lowcost retailers are
actually really popular uh in the United
States so this is on the left is a sort
of the results of a survey from 2019
which shows that you know Amazon counted
as American amica's Best Loved brand and
as you see a lot of these other Big
Brand big risk uh retailers are not very
far behind on the right I confess that's
not the most scientific study in the
world but basically when asked um you
know which companies they love usually
usually Germans are going to go for
their car
companies so the central role played by
uh retail and these big discount
retailers specifically within the US uh
seem to be one of the most distinctive
features of the American political
economy uh and so I set out to try to
explain how we got here so what do we
know about the politics of retailing
there's really a lot of I would say
wonderful work on consumer culture uh
and on consumer credit um uh in um uh by
mostly by economic historians also by uh
sociologists um but almost all of this
work is focused on a particular slice of
time namely the post World War II period
um and most of this work or almost none
of this work is on retail it's on
consumption and consumers but not on
retail specifically which is my
focus so economists uh and management
Scholars who have studied retail have
tended towards sort of apolitical
explanations for the success of these
Mega retailers right it's a story about
the size of the American Market about
technological or organizational
Innovations on the part of these kind of
brilliant entrepreneurs uh that allowed
these companies to grow to dominance uh
Chandler would be kind of the classic on
this but there are also more recent uh
examples of this as well so
unsurprisingly I'm a political scientist
uh the argument that I've developed uh
is more political uh I want to argue
that mass retailers in the United States
were not simply responding to Market
opportunities they were creating them
and they were creating them by
exploiting regulatory gaps as they grew
in scale and
scope so legal Scholars have offered a
somewhat more political version uh of
the story of the rise of these big
retailers so there's of course this
seminal uh article by Lena Khan who was
well known here at uh at Yale um and who
is now of course as you know the head of
the Federal Trade Commission and she
attributed the rise of Amazon uh in
particular to the ascendants of the
so-called Chicago School uh of Law and
economics starting basically in the' 60s
and especially 70s and this is a school
of thought that put uh consumer welfare
uh defined essentially as price at the
center of American antitrust Theory and
jurist Prudence there's a couple of
spots up here if you
like so clearly the rise of The Chicago
School uh has been very important um and
as you're going to hear uh antitrust
actually plays a really big role uh in
the explanation that I've been
developing but where I part ways with at
least that strand of legal scholarship
is that I want to show that the changes
of the 1960s are actually really just
the latest chapter in what is in fact a
much longer story uh one in which large
retailers have basically always enjoyed
an extraordinarily privileged position
within the American anti trust
regime so finally comparative political
economists for their part really haven't
had that much at all to say about the
politics of retail or distribution
generally uh the focus of almost all of
this work and I include my own hello um
I include my own here is just
overwhelmingly on the politics of
production so to the extent that
comparative political economists like
myself have addressed these questions uh
it's a literature that focuses not so
much uh on the politics of retailing uh
but on consumer credit and especially uh
the expansion of Consumer Credit in the
US uh in response to the Great
Depression again this is clearly
important uh but what I want to argue is
that the focus on credit uh has really
tended to obscure the role of these
large discount retailers uh that always
stayed away from credit sales uh but
that I think have had a huge impact not
just on the American Retail Landscape
but on the American political economy as
a whole so this project traces the
origins of what I'm calling the Amazon
economy all the way back to the late
19th century uh this is a period when
these large-scale retailers began to
capitalize on what I see as a uniquely
permissive regulatory landscape in the
US to basically outgrow the capacity of
the government to regulate them so two
features of the American political
economy figure especially prominently in
the explanation that I've been
developing the first is the role of the
American Judiciary and an Anti-Trust
regime that as I want to say from the
beginning gave Mass retailers enormous
advantages and in ways that were
completely distinct from Europe and
second is regulatory fragmentation and
here I basically mean a political
economic landscape that assigned most of
the regulatory powers to State and local
government govern ments which turned out
to be no match for these large retailers
who you know based not least on the head
start that they had received from the
courts were quickly operating on a
national scale so the argument in a
nutshell is that judicial forbearance
and Regulatory Arbitrage allowed large
American retailers to grow and as they
grew they were able to win over an ever
expanding political support Coalition of
groups who over time came to rely on
these big companies in various ways and
then of course uh these groups could
then be weaponized to defend these
companies in their political battles
with wouldbe
Regulators so this is a study that tries
to cover more than a 100 Years of retail
development I'm not going to give you a
sort of blow-by-blow
comprehensive uh treatment here um but
instead what I want to do in this talk
is just zoom in uh on a couple of the
key junctures on the screen here uh
where these Dynamics played out and
whereas I want to show the politics
unfolded very differently uh from Europe
so the first period if you will is the
construction of the mass Market uh in
the late 19th century this is a period
where these mailorder retailers played
an enormously important role uh the
second is the growth of mass consumption
uh in the 1920s this is the period that
saw really the explosion of chain store
retailing uh and the third period is the
post World War II period that saw the
rise to dominance of these big box
discount
retailers so circling back uh starting
with the construction of a mass market
so you know in the late 19th century
there was no Mass Market not in Europe
not in the United States um basically
what you had everywhere is Merchants
scattered all over the place uh each of
these Merchants carried very limited
selection to say the least um they
charged very high prices uh partly
because they were at the end of very
long Supply chains uh but also partly
because each of them of course operated
as a kind of local Monopoly within their
little uh little
area so in Europe consumer co-ops
emerged to challenge these small
merchants and they grew to become the
first mass retailers so you would have
Farmers or workers who would join
together to pool resources in order to
get better prices by purchasing in high
volume and then sell directly to members
these local cooperatives would then
scale up by developing ties to
cooperatives in other regions sort of
the other localities and regions sort of
growing from the bottom up and out until
they grew to National in some cases uh
International scale so this was
happening throughout Europe most
famously I would say in Scandinavia uh
where cooperatives are actually still
major players uh in the Retail
Landscape but actually the earliest and
most successful example of this uh
emerged in what is America's closest
cousin namely
Britain and this took the form of the
Cooperative wholesale society which grew
out of these local cooperatives but that
really took off after legislation in the
1850s and especially 60s uh allowed
individual cooperatives to coordinate
their activities okay and so that is
what allowed for the formation of a
National Society a co-op of co-ops if
you will um that became you know grew to
become the biggest retailer not just in
Britain uh but in the world uh by the
end of the 19th century and then as in
other countries this National
Cooperative Association uh in Britain
also then began integrating backward in
order to start producing some of the
goods that they sold and what so what
you see on the right here is the um is
one of their production
facilities so similar Cooperative
Ventures were also getting founded in
the US in the late 19th century so some
of you of course will know about the gra
movement and its successor the farmers
Alliance these were important in
American history as the main
organizations uh that farmers developed
uh to advance both their economic
interests but also to channel their
political Grievances and these were of
course uh associations that became
hugely important uh in the populist
Revolt uh against Monopoly power in the
late 19th century so starting in the
1860s these local grain chapters
organized themselves into cooperatives
both to try to secure higher prices for
their own Goods but also to try to pool
orders to secure uh lower costs for
their members uh on consumer
goods unlike in Europe though these
efforts were not really met by state
support or even forbearance uh in fact
even as cooperatives in Europe were
really flourishing in this period they
failed to thrive and grow in the United
States and one of the bigger obstacles
that they faced was this fragmented and
fractured and far less congenial legal
landscape so it's a complicated story uh
but the short version of the story is
that unlike in Europe there was no
National legislation in the late 19th
century that could clarify the legal
standing of these cooperatives uh and
that expressly sanctioned their
activities this was getting decided in
the courts uh and while courts in some
some states saw no problem with these
cooperatives especially starting in the
1880s courts in other states began to
view the kind of joint marketing and uh
distribution that really stood at the
center of the Cooperative project as
price fixing and thus running a foul of
common law prohibitions against
conspiracies in Restraint of trade so at
this point sometimes state legislators
would step in and pass a law trying to
exempt these cooperatives from
prosecution but federal court often took
a pretty hard line on this uh and struck
down some of these state laws as
unconstitutional either on grounds of
equal protection or after the Sherman
Antitrust Act of 1890 um as violations
of federal uh antitrust laws and this is
of course paradoxical uh because these
agrarian interests um had provided a
great deal of the impetus uh behind the
Sherman Antitrust Act uh which was
supposed to be directed against the JP
Morgans uh and Rockefellers of the world
but which often came to be um deployed
against their own Cooperative
associations so the failure of those
Ventures then provided a huge opening
for private corporations to basically
move into this space because individual
companies that organized all these
marketing and distribution functions
internally uh were of course outside the
scope of these antitrust laws there's no
collusion no conspiracy if you're within
a single uh private entity or company so
Montgomery Ward was really the first one
to kind of open the vast consumer
markets uh of the American west and
south uh but it was this guy uh Richard
Warren Sears who really came to dominate
this market and so he moved in with an
extraordinarily aggressive strategy of
very high volume sales very thin margins
very low prices and on a really insanely
wide range uh of products so when it was
founded in 188 86 the Sears catalog if
you want to call it a catalog was just a
one-page flyer all he sold was watches
um but within just 20 years just two
decades this catalog was thousands of
pages long you could literally buy
everything from toothbrushes to entire
prefabricated houses that would come to
you with all the mill work done and um
you know sort of instructions for how to
reassemble them right so it's sort of
like uh ordering an Ikea or something
like that some of these seirs houses are
actually still standing uh in the
American Midwest many of them are in are
in Illinois you can visit them so the
expansion of these companies across the
US would not have been possible had it
not been for the way in which uh they
were able to exploit existing public
infrastructure for private purposes and
here the US Postal System played an
absolutely critical role because this is
what provided these companies not just
just with a subsidized means of getting
their cataloges and their goods to this
widely dispersed rural population uh but
also I would say much more importantly
local post offices were able to serve as
a critical intermed intermediary in the
financial transactions that these
companies were having with their
customers so as I said in Europe these
cooperatives had grown kind of from the
bottom up and out right through
Federation so they had local branches
all over the place they could sell
things for cash uh or they could let
people run a tab Montgomery Ward and
Sears of course by definition did not
have retail outlets uh and moreover
virtually all of their rural customers
were unbanked they had no bank accounts
they were operating basically on a cash
or barter economy so how are you going
to do these long distance sales well you
could of course send uh cash through the
mail but it but as you know if you've
seen American westerns stage coaches
were constantly getting you know that
were carrying the ma mail were
constantly getting held up which is why
this guy has his has his hands up in the
air so none of this actually would have
been possible without the money order
system that the US Postal System offered
so this was a service that the
government had introduced earlier and
for completely different reasons uh in
the Civil War uh in order to allow Union
Soldiers B basically to get their money
back home uh
safely but these retailers were able to
repurpose this service to serve as a
critical Financial intermediary in their
transactions with uh with customers and
just to give you a sense of how much a
company like Sears for example depended
on the infrastructure of the US Postal
System here are the instructions from a
se's catalog from 1908 says if you live
on a rural mail route just give the
letter and the money to the mail carrier
and he will get the money order at the
Post Office and mail it in the letter
for you so this is how America's first
mass retailers were able to reach and
win over uh millions of customers who
now had access to this unlimited range
of standardized consumer goods and at
prices their local Merchants could not
hope to match and once they had this
loyal I would say more or less captive
uh consumer base they could also
mobilize them um as a powerful Ally in
their political battles and one of the
most important of those battles was to
secure legislation to expand postal
services to carry more uh and bigger
packages so parcel
post this is something that's obviously
of clear value to Sears uh but very much
opposed both by the express the big
Express companies that you otherwise had
to pay uh to transport all those goods
and and by the small Merchants that cirs
was of course putting out of business at
this time so when legislation on parcel
post was being considered Mass retailers
actively weaponized their rural
consumers uh among other ways
encouraging them to basically blanket
congress with petitions which they did
and so what you see on the right here is
that petitions in favor of parcel post
uh spiked at precisely the moments when
Congress was considering legislation
to fund this service and those were
coming from exactly these areas so when
it came time for the vote uh virtually
all of the support that carried this
legislation uh came from Democrats in
the rural South and West which is what
you see in the dark blue here these were
exactly the areas uh that relied
virtually entirely uh on mail order
companies in order to link them into
this National
Market parcel post then ushered in a
kind of golden a age uh of mail order
Sears saw its sales increase fivefold in
just the first year of parcel post umy
Ward as you see was not far behind so in
some in this first period these large
male order companies enjoyed extremely
favorable treatment under American
antitrust they proceeded to grow by
exploiting and repurposing public
infrastructure for private ends uh and
American farmers of course who otherwise
were battling big business they did not
battle these companies they in fact
welcomed them with open arms because it
liberated them from this these
high-priced local markets bringing them
a kind of world of exotic new consumer
goods this then sets the scene for the
explosive growth of these chain stores
uh in the early 20th century so the
early 20th century and the in war period
the Progressive Era and the and the
so-called Roaring 20s is this really
paradoxical period uh in American
history one that was characterized
simultaneously by high and Rising
inequality both wealth uh inequality
which is in the blue or kind of green
here um and income inequality uh but it
was also a period that saw a real boom
in consumption and consumer spending so
Americans were buying things like
washing machines and vacuum cleaners
really decades before their counterparts
uh in Europe so how did the average
American get all this stuff um part of
the answer is that established retailers
by which by now of course includes Sears
they were already selling things uh on
credit uh and that's another story of
regulatory Arbitrage that I try to tell
in the book um basically the the
expansion of Consumer Credit in this
period um expanded really in a in a
legal Gray Zone very much sort of under
the uh under the radar um
but the and I can talk more about that
in the Q&A if you like the other
development though that fueled
consumption in the 1920s was the really
phenomenal growth of chain stores which
operated on a cashon basis okay so you
had new entrance to the retail sector
Woolworths JC peny Ben Franklin they did
not offer credit um they were competing
exclusively on price so these chains
grew extraordinarily rapidly uh in just
these 10 years so just 10 years I put
some figures on the screen just to give
you a sense uh of the explosion of these
chain stores in this period what you
also see at the bottom of the screen is
that the numbers in Europe are much
lower so where variety chains already
were accounting for nearly a quarter of
retail turnover in the US uh they were
uh only accounting for 7% in England and
under 2% in other countries on the
continent and this was in large part
because these kinds of operations were
encountering much stiffer headwinds uh
in uh in Europe uh in other words the
politics were again playing out very
differently on the other side of the
Atlantic so these conflicts centered on
two issues one was resale price
maintenance arrangements and the other
was special taxes on large retailers and
I just want to talk briefly about each
of these in order to underscore the
differences uh to Europe at the time
so resale price maintenance Arrangements
involve contracts through which
manufacturers commit retailers to charge
a specific usually minimum price for
their goods so this is promoted by
manufacturers of patented Goods who want
to protect the reputation of their
brands but of course small retailers
also love these Arrangements because if
everybody had to charge the same price
this would relieve them of price
competition from these larger uh more
efficient uh producers so in that sense
resale price maintenance kind of
reflected or maybe created a kind of
alliance between brand manufacturers and
small merchants on one hand against
these larger uh lowcost retailers who at
the time were already advocating
specifically explicitly uh the right for
what they called the right to cut
prices so resale price maintenance
contracts were perfectly legal and
indeed widespread in Europe throughout
this period throughout the interwar
period and indeed well into the second
the the post World War II period um
mostly they were uh uh they survived
until the 1960s in Germany resale price
maintenance was only banned in
1974 uh and this too goes back to this
different approach to competition policy
because unlike in the US courts in
Europe in the early 20th century were uh
adhering to the principle of of freedom
of contract but including um recognizing
contra contracts that under American law
would have been considered
anti-competitive so resale price
maintenance uh Arrangements were not
just legal in European coordinated
market economies this you might expect
um but also in Britain again a fellow
liberal market economy uh and also uh
one that shares America's common law
tradition so the organizational vehicle
through which these uh Arrangements
operated was the British proprietary
trade assoc trade Association this was
founded in
1896 uh and this was an outfit that
brought together manufacturers
wholesalers and re retailers who jointly
administered uh and policed a a list of
protected prices on trademarked Goods so
what I'm about to describe would have
been 100% illegal in the US but the way
it worked is that manufacturers set
their prices retailers would then
monitor those prices they would notify
the association if some retailer was
found to be undercutting that price and
then the association would collectively
enforce the manufacturer's price by
putting that retailer on a so-called
stop list and being on the stop list
then obliged all other Association
members to stop supplying that uh that
firm so or that retailer so small
independent retailers were beneficiaries
of this because this channeled retail
competition in Britain away from Price
uh and toward price uh competition
centering more on uh quality and on
service so the situation in the US was
radically different um from very early
on starting in at the latest in 1911 the
Supreme Court ruled that resale price
maintenance Arrangements uh were per se
illegal under prevailing antitrust um
and the landmark case here was one that
pitted a large discount uh drugstore a
Price Cutter uh against a small
manufacturer of patented medicine uh and
in this case the uh Court ruled in favor
of the big drug chain basically giving
retailers uh control over the prices
they
charged so this case was controversial
uh it inspired the formation of a
so-called fair trade League uh that
advocated changes in antitrust law to
try to allow smaller firms to engage in
Greater coordination to protect
themselves from Domination by these
larger entities and to steer competition
especially to steer competition away
from price and toward Innovation and
quality so the fair trade League had
some very prominent uh Advocates
including uh future Supreme Court
Justice Lewis brandise uh among others
and brandise was actually well aware of
what was happening in Europe and he
really admired some of the aspects of
the alternative model of what he called
regulated competition that he saw
developing there at the time so he and
other Progressive saw this ban on resale
price maintenance as really just
encouraging ruinous price competition uh
he called it competition that kills uh
this would inspire a race to the bottom
it would lead to Monopoly especially
because it would kill off all of these
smaller Innovative
competitors but American F free Traders
were really quite styed in the courts
really throughout the 1920s in other
words precisely through that period
which as I just pointed out was when
these chain stores were were
experiencing their most explosive growth
so the situation changed a little bit in
the early 1930s in the midst now we're
in the midst of the Great Depression
brandise is by this time of course on
the bench uh and the Supreme Court did
relax what rules States could pass in
this area and some states in fact many
states uh did pass fair trade
legislation but very different from
Europe brand manufacturers could still
not legally and openly enlist the help
uh of other retailers or other producers
in defending the prices that they set
that would still be illegal so
enforcement ran entirely through private
litigation and private litigation was
extraordinarily expensive uh for most
firms and it was certainly uh too
expensive for most of the small firms
that brandise and others had really
sought uh to protect just to give you
one example at one point General
Electric was pursuing 3,000 different
lawsuits against various companies for
violating its uh its contracts which is
a huge legal expense these small
companies couldn't
match moreover state laws of course uh
only cover intrastate trade so this did
not really stop these chains that had
now grown to national scale uh and that
could engage in regulatory Arbitrage
basically switching up their sourcing in
order to avoid fair trade States or just
buying the uh entire output uh of a
single supplier so chain store age which
was and still is actually the main uh
chain store magazine was constantly a
publishing tips on how to work around
these uh around these laws so basically
too little and and and arguably too
late running parallel to all of these
battles over resale price maintenance
during the Depression were other efforts
to slow down the chains in other ways uh
and this took the form of efforts to
impose heavy taxes on chain stores this
is again something that small retailers
uh would have loved to see and so what
you have on the screen here is just a
kind of sample of some of the rhetoric
of the time these guys are you know
vicious Price Cutters they're running
legitimate retailers out of business
they're callous foreign entities that
don't contribute anything uh to the
local economy so a lot of these
campaigns against the chains were really
pretty successful uh particularly in the
South uh and well yeah South and West um
and this is because this was coming at a
time when these small variety chains
were moving in and really placing a lot
of pressure on uh on local businesses
businesses that were in the context of
the depression of course uh already
suffering from the from the
downturn it's also the depression uh and
so populism is enjoying a Renaissance at
this point you have people you know Wall
Street Bankers are being uh blamed for
the depression you have populists like
uh huie long saying I would rather have
thieves and gangsters than chain stores
in
Louisiana so in fact uh chain store
taxes did get passed uh in many of these
uh or in some of these states at least
uh but again they ran into trouble uh in
the courts certainly in the 1920s when
chain store taxes were getting stck
struck down again on equal protection
grounds under the 14th Amendment and
even when these taxes were not getting
struck down chains were just engaging in
the same sorts of regulatory Arbitrage
sort of reorganizing their operations in
order to avoid these taxes or to
minimize their obligations under
them so state level regulation uh was
clearly ineffective and so this all
culminated in 1938 in one big I would
say kind of last ditch effort to impose
a chain store tax at the national level
um and that was uh an effort that was
spearheaded by this guy Texas
representative Wright Patman who some
people have called uh America's last
populist but his proposal for this
national chain store tax really went
down in flames because by this time
chains were able to mobilize their
allies in huge public relations
campaigns so so they did things like
sponsor referenda in order to mobilize
voters and so on the right here uh you
see just an example of this this is from
a referendum in Utah uh where basically
the chains are saying uh you know if you
put taxes on us or if you raise taxes on
us that's simply going to uh result in
higher prices for
you so by the time things uh you know by
the time it came time uh to consider
Pat's legislation a whole bunch of
groups kind of came out of the woodwork
uh to defend the chains so you had
farmers and farm organizations turning
out uh in the Congressional hearings uh
to defend the chains because in the
meantime they had come to depend on
these grocery chains uh as an efficient
way to Mo to distribute their products
and also and especially uh to unload
periodic surpluses which was of course a
big problem for American farmers you had
manufacturers even the manufacturers who
had previously fought the chains on
prices um now they climbed on board uh
because they were of course extremely
Capital intensive and so now this
economic downturn had sort of taught
them to appreciate uh the kind of
flexibil the kind of PR predictability
that these large uh uh retailers
provided because they ordered in very
large volume and um and well in
advance and finally you know consumers
were basically hooked on the chains uh
consumers in the US have historically
been uh represented uh by women clubs by
women's groups uh and so women's groups
also turned out in the Congressional
hearings uh to defend the chains as a
kind of go-to source for lowcost goods
uh so by the late 1930s already just a
few years after it had gotten going this
chain store taxation movement was now
kind of spent uh now you had States
repealing their chain store taxes um now
in fact you had uh states often
competing to have these lower cost
retailers locate in their jurisdictions
and so this is uh an article from The
New York Times from 19
1939 here's a national survey that was
fielded in 1938 just when this national
chain store tax uh was being considered
and people were asked well what do you
think would be the best policy toward
the chain stores and basically what you
see here is that now most Americans
thought that they should be left alone
to quote make what profits they can
rather than tax them extra and certainly
um not to get rid of them entirely which
had been Pat's uh objective there so
again the politics of retailing uh in
the 1920s and 30s in the US were really
strikingly different uh from Europe
large retailers had already benefited
from this enormous Head Start by virtue
of this ban on resale price maintenance
uh and once they were operating on a
national scale they were able to really
work work around whatever state laws
were getting it passed in this uh
fractured fragmented regulatory
landscape and again as they grew they
were assembling this ever expanding kind
of support Coalition that they were
mobilizing whenever they faced a new
regulatory
threat so finally and very briefly to
the post World War II period this is of
course the period that saw the kind of
full flowering uh of America's
consumption-driven growth model um this
is the period that's really famous for
the Boom in construct uh in consumption
largely as a result of government
sponsored housing loans um at least for
white middle class families uh this is
the period that saw the growth uh of
these suburbs and these um Suburban
malls that I was talking about at the
beginning uh but even as these new
Suburban shopping centers were
reconfiguring the geography of shopping
you had disruptive new uh entrance to
the retail sector that would really
redefine the temporal bounds of shopping
as well so as I mentioned at the outset
despite some liberalization really uh in
general shopping hours in Europe are
simply a lot more regulated than they
are in the United States you have
shorter days but also in particular you
have a lot more restrictions on Sunday
on Sunday shopping and actually that was
the case in the US as well Sunday
shopping was really not a thing uh in
the immediate post World War II years um
shops were generally closed um but all
of this started falling apart in the
1960s with the arrival of these very
disruptive new Discounters so you had a
bunch of kind of small operations that
flamed out pretty quickly those are the
ones on the left like Corvettes was one
of the most famous of these but this is
also the period that saw the founding of
some of these bigger more durable chains
and so Kmart and Walmart H and Target
all three of those uh were actually
founded in the same year in
1962 and all of these Discounters they
were challenging established retailers
not just on price though of course
absolutely on price um but also simply
by staying open both evenings and also
on Sundays which at the time again was
not a thing so again small retailers and
their allies mobilized to try to impos
some restrictions here they were joined
by religious groups often they were
actually also joined by some of the big
department stores uh because Department
Stores of course had higher Staffing and
therefore higher labor costs and they
weren't interested in in having the
extended hours uh but again you get the
same basic story you again you have a
flurry of state and local legislation
that attempts to regulate Sunday selling
these laws took a a variety of tax some
of them tried to ban the sale of items
other than Necessities some of them
tried to limit Sunday selling to
particular kinds of retailers uh some of
them tried to prohibit uh only big
stores from staying open on uh on
Sundays um but even where these laws
were passed these Discounters often just
flagrantly ignored the rules and simply
paid the fines they were basically
absorbing these legal costs just another
business expense it reminds me very much
uh of the way that Uber entered Local
transportation markets basically Uber
just came in ignored in the US at least
ignored local Transportation laws um and
simply paid the fines while they while
they scaled
up so in Europe this kind of rule
breaking uh met with the opposition not
just of small Merchants uh but also of
religious groups and unions uh but in
the us where unions were much weaker uh
enforcement tended to run through the
courts uh and when these things got
litigated retailers actually often won
and they were able to Prevail um often
because they could claim a
discriminatory treatment which met with
a lot of sympathy uh in US courts
because they have often strong aversions
to any kind of government intervention
that might smack of uh of legislative uh
favoritism most importantly though while
these cases dragged on these stores just
stayed open um and the people got used
to it uh and once they got used to it
they wanted to keep it and so here's a
survey from the mid
1970s uh which as again a national
survey asking how would you feel about a
law against stores being open on Sundays
and as you see here a huge majority by
this time uh opposed that and even
actually when when when the uh when uh
state laws did say yes you may try to uh
legislate or you may try to restrict
Sunday hours um basically enforcement
was just a huge problem how would you
know who were the police supposed to
supposed to uh arrest Shoppers managers
it just wasn't wasn't clear um so all of
this kind of culminated in an important
case before the New York uh circuit uh
New York Court of Appeals uh that threw
out a state law that had been trying to
limit uh shopping hours and the court
did So based on the observation that
those laws seem to be incoherent they
seem to be
unenforceable um and this was dangerous
because this uh encouraged what the
court considered to be uh an erosive
disrespect of the
law so over the next years basically
what happened is that all of these
states abandoned their uh legal
prohibitions either explicitly or often
more often they just stopped enforcing
them uh and this is how we ended up with
this uniquely uh in inter sort of
compared to other Rich democracies a
uniquely unregulated a shopping hour
regime uh that we have
today so I want to forego the usual kind
of conclusion and so instead um I want
to wrap up this talk not by sort of
repeating the argument or by summarizing
the argument but by stepping back and
sort of panning out a little bit to
highlight the sign ific of these
developments for the American political
economy as a whole and I want to also
try to situate this study in the context
of some of my previous work um on
inequality and particularly inequality
at the lowi income uh at the low end of
the income ladder so one of the reasons
that I think it's really important uh to
think about the uh the evolution of
discount retailing specifically
alongside the other sort I think much
better known story of the role of credit
uh within the post-war American
political economy is that it gives us a
somewhat different angle on the crisis
of American
manufacturing and on Rising inequality
in the US uh since the
1970s so as I've tried to point out in
some of my previous work on Labor and
labor markets one of the ways in which
the US really stands out in
international comparisons is for the
really large size of the low pay sector
and so what you see on the screen here
are oecd figures on the share of low pay
um uh share of uh the size of the low
pay sector as a percentage of the uh
full Workforce low Pay Here defined as
less than earning less than two uh
2third of median income and what you see
is that the US is at the at the high end
among its peers um the same story are
much the same story as true uh if you
look at in work poverty I don't have the
comparative figures but I just looked at
the most recent figures for the US um
which is from 2021 that show that nearly
15% of Americans live in households uh
with incomes below 60% of median
disposable income and to put that in
perspective the oecd average is
99.3% so again very very much at the
high end beyond that and again as I've
tried to point out in some of my other
uh other work these loway jobs in the US
really just don't come with a lot of the
benefits that are taken for granted in
Europe right healthc care benefits there
is in this country no federally
guaranteed paytime off there is in this
country no federally guaranteed vacation
days there's no rules uh regarding
scheduling and so precarious workers uh
in particular are often subject to
extraordinarily uh irregular unstable
work hours these are all ways in which
the US is an enormous outlier in
international uh uh perspective and
these types of precarious working
relationships have really grown
especially since the
1970s so a common you know not
unreasonable explanation for that is
that the is the decline of American
manufacturing uh in the face of you know
competition from lower cost producers
abroad and that's of course what's seen
as having destroyed all these kind of
better paid unionized manufacturing jobs
um and that's what left us with a lot of
low skill low uh low pay uh service
sector
jobs that account is of course not wrong
but I think it's radically incomplete uh
because in that model the pressures on
American manufacturing are entirely
exogenous you know American retailers
are not seen as having played any
particular role here uh they're just
seen as some kind of a passive uh
transmission belt these stores are just
offering consumers a choice uh and
consumers are going for the lower
prices but in the story that I'm trying
to tell these large lowcost retailers
are really playing a much more active
role in accelerating the decline of
American manufacturing and undermining
the American growth model more generally
I think it's really important uh that
the factors that I'm trying to highlight
here this legal regime and the fractured
regulatory landscape that promoted a
particular model model of retailing to
dominance it's an ultr lean retailing
model it's based on extremely narrow
margins it's dominated by big players
Walmart now Amazon that enjoy enormous
power both over workers and over their
suppliers so of course these companies
one of the things that they're doing is
that they're cutting their own labor
costs to the Bone and as you see here
that's a very old recipe that goes all
the way back to you know Frank Woolworth
who was in 1892 two already was saying
we must have cheap help or we can't sell
cheap goods and as you see I put some
figures here as you see um retail
workers in the US themselves make up a
very significant share of this American
precariat that I was talking about over
three4 of them fall in that low wage
category that I just showed you um fully
15% of them qualify for Medicaid um
according to a recent study 2022 study
from the government accountability
office Amazon and especially Walmart uh
are among the top employers whose
workers depend on SNAP benefits what we
used to call uh food
stabs beyond their own labor model
though these dominant Discounters have
also been extraordinarily aggressive in
forcing the manufacturers and the
vendors who Supply them to accept ever
narrower margins and therefore to cut
their own costs so Walmart is of course
famous for uh it's you know using its
dominance to extract extremely low
prices from its suppliers many of whom
rely really very heavily on this single
uh company for a huge share of their
total sales and these are pressures of
course that that you know in the 1970s
these producers began passing on to
workers first in the form of you know
first by moving to the non-union South
and later by Outsourcing uh or
subcontracting with lower cost producers
abroad and similarly today of course
Amazon is able to extract really high
fees from many of the third-party
sellers who are literally existentially
reliant on this platform in order to
reach their
customers and what makes these companies
hard to regulate especially in the US is
that just as in the past all the while
they're actively cultivating this large
loyal customer base
so Prime Membership uh globally is now
up to about 200 million uh fully more
than 3/4 of them are are Americans that
may be not so surprising it's an
American company but what did surprise
me is that fully 2third uh of all online
Shoppers in the United States and that's
a lot of people uh are Amazon Prime
members so you begin to get a kind of
normalization of these relationships and
growing popularity as more and more
people come to kind of depend on these
Services uh and and start to think that
it's perfectly normal uh to expect these
low priced Goods to be delivered to
their door delivered to their door by
many of these precarious workers that I
was just talking about delivered within
used to be 48 hours now it's 24
increasingly it's uh in some places um
same day service and then once you're in
this cycle of you know low margins and
low wages you also then begin to have
this population of low-income workers
who rely on these lowcost retailers to
make ends meet right so so in this
context these large discount retailers
have paradoxically kind of become part
of the infrastructure of the lives of
many citizens and not just for the low
prices that they offer right for people
like me or probably most of the people
in this room who have you know pretty
good pay very flexible job you know we
may prefer to shop at our local at our
local stores that's my local bookstore
on the left there but for people with
low incomes people who work really long
hours sometimes two jobs people who have
no paid time off no vacation days and
certainly can't pay the high cost of um
of daycare for people like that and
that's a really large share of Americans
um it's not an option necessarily to
shop around at a lot of smaller SP
specialty stores it may seem more
realistic just to go to some big box
store at whatever time of night and day
and buy everything you need at this low
price kind of Allin one
go finally it's not just consumers who
have come to rely on these big retailers
so when the pandemic hit um you know
European countries mobilized their
health care infrastructure in order to
uh administer vaccines right in the US
what happened in the US the the
government turned to these big retailers
CVS Walgreens and Walmart as kind of a
key part of the essential infrastructure
to vaccinate the public so Walmart
played a really Central role in reaching
rural communities that are otherwise
completely underserved by the American
Health Care System they played a big
role in reaching lowincome groups that
again lack the paid time off that you
might need to visit a clinic during the
day you could go to Walmart Walmart at
10 p.m. and get your shot these are
things that Americans kind of take for
granted or don't think that much about
uh but they are highly anomalous to
Europeans I mean my European friends
were shocked to hear that I got one of
my shots at a Walmart right so my point
is absolutely not to celebrate these uh
big Discounters I hope I've made
eminently clear that I'm a Critic
particularly of their labor model uh I
just want to point out that the US is in
a very deep equilibrium here one that is
I think sustained not just by the
popularity of these big retailers though
that too but also really by the
infrastructural role that they have come
to play in the lives of many citizens so
thank you very much I'm looking forward
to
your
thank you so much we have plenty of time
for
QA 5:30 so let's open the floor for
questions and maybe we can give a chance
to
students
first hi Amy um like you kind of
mentioned your and there there's that
paradoxical relationship that exists
where um a lot of like lower income
people um are simultaneously hurt by the
the big retailers that exist but also
sort of depend on them in order to get
basic goods and necessities and things
like that what do you think the most
like actionable way to move like is to
move forward and you know able to solve
like be able to solve the the fact that
these low-income people um stop stop
getting corrupted by these or real
chillers but also still have access to
basic necessities and things like that
okay great thank you it's a great
question
so policy I mean my whole my whole
message is that policy and politics got
us into this deep equilibrium and I
believe that policy and politics are the
way out of this uh out of this bind as
well um I don't have a ton of faith in
Solutions like um kind of collective
self-restraint on the part of consumers
I think I'm sort of everything all the
work that I've ever done on platforms um
this this and other kinds of platforms
um doesn't give me a whole lot of faith
that just you know sort of asking
consumers to sort of like don't do it um
isn't going to get us very far and so
you know I'm my friend Jenny Mansbridge
um has a theory of you know uh
legitimate coercion the role of
government is to um to Eng to to pass
policies that involve legitimate
coercion sort of to force um to to to to
use policy to force people to do things
that they wouldn't otherwise do and to
um place you know sort of solve societal
Collective action problems through
policy and so the two that I would point
to would be um first of all I think um
Anti-Trust uh uh legislation is really
important and I think that I mean I
basically agree with Lena Khan who's
currently um a head of FDC that these
are structural problems they require
structural Solutions I think the EU has
uh shown the way in some um in some
areas of of how to um restrain some of
these big uh these big sellers in terms
of like limits on predatory pricing
limits on uh discriminatory treatment
and things like that it's still in still
in development but I think there are
there are models there and then you know
I'm a labor scholar and so labor law
reform is absolutely um is absolutely
essential um so one of the things that I
try to do in the book is I I I and I
didn't have time to do in the talk is I
compare the labor you know the situation
in the retail Market in European
countries and in uh and in the US and
you know in all of these countries you
know retail workers are not very well
organized but in Europe they're far
better covered by Collective contracts
that you know ulate wages that regulate
working hours that that that that
provide you know some of these some of
these core foundational uh rights um
that in this country are seen as like um
fringe benefits or something that you
that you might get if your employer is
sort of uh is sort of um particularly
generous or something like that um so
yeah those would be the two the two and
especially on labor law reform I just
think that it's absolutely critical and
again we have you know it's a moment of
of Labor um activism and so I have
actually quite a lot of hope that
there's that that things could move in
that direction as
well um so turning to the point you made
about um political mobilization and the
ability of these retailers to kind of
Leverage their essential Services um to
you know generate Goodwill that they can
call upon you know in moments of you
know potential regulation I'm wondering
um if you think that contemporarily um
we're kind of running up against the
limits of that and that um it seemed
like the capacity of of Corporations to
um kind of in that way leverage um
public support against regulations seem
produced um and that kind of challenges
to fot on in terms of like antitrust but
also in terms of um you know labor
organizing um
they
seem um and this is anecdotal but like
increasingly successful in kind of
challenging them despite the fact that
um you know uh you have a corporation
like Amazon that kind of makes it
explicit that that business model is
dependent on um low wage labor and so
I'm wondering um about like the
Contemporary possibilities for
challenging um
retailers um despite this history of
kind of Goodwill and this sense of of
kind of belovedness among population
right so um so one of the things that's
distinctive and that's different about
Europe that versus the United thanks for
coming um one of the things that's
different is that there are very few
sort of countervailing forces organized
interests counterveiling that are
capable of counterveiling the power of
these monopolis or would be monopolis
right so it's like they can develop this
this direct relationship to Consumers
because there are very few sort of
intermediary organizations that can sort
of perform counterveiling functions and
so you know Unions would be one these
are these are associations that have
actually a presence and that have
performed counterveiling uh uh uh
functions in Europe but that are sort of
absent or extremely weak in the United
States and so I've already talked about
Labor the other one I would say is
actually trade associations organized
employers um because in a lot of the
work that I've done on again on these
platforms especially platforms that kind
of move in and uh come to dominate and
often are doing so um by working in sort
of gray areas or sort of even even
illegally to begin um and just kind of
paying these fines and stuff like that
um one of the most important
countervailing forces in in in many
European countries is organized employer
interests because organized employers
also don't have a big interest in some
uh firm gaining gaining uh gaining a
foothold in the in the market uh and
they would much prefer sort of who
especially those who have sort of
monopolistic uh Ambitions right so they
are often Defenders of a well-regulated
u Market one that certainly sort of uh
uh um certainly puts up some barriers to
the kinds of illegal or sort of
semi-legal um uh tactics that are often
used in the early phases in order to
gain uh to gain scale so this is again
one of the I think casualties of um
American
antitrust um because you know going all
the way back to the late 19 century um
what we know is that um the American I
mean the story that everybody kind of I
think knows is that antitrust was used
against unions and one of the reasons
that unions are so weak is because
uh unions op organized on a more
Industrial Level were sort of
disarticulated partly because they were
constantly facing um conspiracy charges
and so forth but another big casualty of
that period that people don't talk as
much about uh is trade associations
trade associations were very much
enfeebled in this period because the
courts in the United States again
distinctively and very unlike what was
going on in Europe courts in the United
States were um were extremely averse
were extremely negative toward uh any
form of horizontal coordination among
small competitors it's to do with what
the period that I talked about when when
brandise was saying well shouldn't we
let these small competitors sort of
coordinate their activities in order to
you know be able to hold their own
against these dominant players um and he
was actually an advocate of something
like would have been you know stronger
trade Association ations and they really
atrophied in this uh in this country and
they atrophied because while antitrust
was very forbearing toward um toward
large you know conglomerate kinds of
companies because everything with
everything organized all the functions
organized within a single entity there's
no collusion there's no conspiracy but
as soon as there was any kind of
horizontal coordination whether by
unions whether by workers or by small uh
small retailers or small businesses um
that actually ran a foul of American
antitrust and so you know fast forward
to the present those are exactly the
kinds of counterveiling forces that are
actually that are actually more
effective I would say politically than
sort of organized or sort of collective
self-restraint on the part of uh of of
um consumers who have like you know for
whom coordinate you sort of collective
action problems are just like
insurmountable
um should I do
something um I had a question about what
you think what effect are Technologies
going to have like specifically on I'm
thinking about just like Trends in
eCommerce and how expensive it is to
have the digital infrastructure and
logistics for that which obviously will
make it harder to compete for um smaller
retailers but also in terms of Labor and
and um potentially being able to cut
costs on that like using um AI or other
forms of technology and whether you
think that's something that can be
regulated um well yeah I mean the data
is really crucial to these big these big
platforms and and you know or these big
retailers generally so of Walmart as
well um and it does two things like the
the there's a kind of there's always
been a kind of balance of power and a
kind of tension you'd think that mass
retail and mass manufacturing would kind
of go together they'd be sort of
symbiotically related to one another but
in fact at many points they've really
been at loggerheads with one another
over things like pricing um and so the
the balance of power has shifted very
much in favor of uh large uh large um
retailers who now have the data to be
able to dictate to their suppliers you
know they know when you know what is
selling at what price in combination
with what other things in what locations
and so they're able to really use that
to to dominate uh the the suppliers that
the suppliers and vendors that they that
they that they get the goods from um so
the data the the use of Technology um
that's something that has really
redounded to the to the benefit of these
big uh of these big um of these big
retailers and the same thing with labor
Brian Rogers has just written a
wonderful book on the way in which um
these big companies not just you know
Walmart and and and uh and Amazon
although that those two in also um is
used to surveil workers is used to
control workers and is used to sort of
um sort of speed up uh you know sort of
accelerate uh work um in various ways in
that you know that is coded in the
United States under current antitrust um
or at least Chicago School antitrust
thinking as efficient but that is in
fact uh extraordinarily
exploitative um and so so far I would
say that the that the data that the the
sort of the technology has has operated
to tilt the balance of power further in
favor of uh retailers both Visa V
manufacturers and Visa v um uh workers
can you do something about that yeah um
and again I mean I hate to keep saying
but the EU is actually doing some stuff
in that regard that is that protects um
that sort of places some limits on the
extent to which these big retailers can
use their their their access to data in
order to I don't know cannibalize um
like for Amazon there's a rule that
limits their ability to cannibalize um
their thirdparty sellers like Amazon has
this strategy where if they see
something because they have the data if
they see something is selling
particularly well they'll jump in and
and do an Amazon basic knockoff of that
product and so there are some limits on
that and similarly one of the things
that is pretty foundational to labor law
in most of Europe is limitations on on
the use of data to surveil workers
certainly not you certainly can't
surveil them um when it comes to
organizing activities and you also can't
surveil them in in terms of their sort
of the everyday pace of work so again I
think so far it hasn't worked that way
in the US but that's again policy
politics could could reequilibrate
things a at least a little bit
hi thank you so much uh premise I'm from
Europe and perhaps because of that I'm
not so positive about the part of the
world that I come from and I'm wondering
whether you you think that Europe will
be going in the same direction of the US
because while like we obviously have a
very strong welfare state in certain
countries of the European Union in
particular in the south
we are so severely underpaid that we
necessarily have to rely on big
retailers so if you gave the same speech
I work at the European University
Institute most people most PhD will be
amongst those who are so severely
underpaid that we cannot really afford
to be the consumer who chooses between
different things and while it's true
that the U is doing certain things like
a AI act will regulate uh the control
that retailers can have and the use of
data Etc but there are other Norms that
still especially regarding consumption
that are so that have a very strong
Market bias and that are using as a
legal basis the integration of the
internal market and that is pushing for
massive consumption if you read even the
new proposals on sustainable consumption
it's almost because the the summaries
and the recital said that having a
variety of products constantly
circulating within the internal Market
is still your number one's priority so
that pushes towards this type of
consumption so I'm I'm curious to to
know whether you you're positive as what
will happen the you or whether we are
coming closer to you uh it's certainly
the case it's certainly the case that uh
yeah absolutely there are certainly
trends that I signaled this but I didn't
maybe talk enough about it there are
certainly Trends in Europe that are that
are sort of converging on the American
on the American model of uh of
consumption in some in some ways um I
will say and and and there are certain
ways in which you know some of these
constraints that I was talking about
like shopping hours I mean when it comes
to e-commerce shopping hours is like
imaginal line that is like long since
been breached right there's no limit as
to when and how and and where people can
shop right um I so I I absolutely take
your point I do think that there has
been some convergence I do still see
though that um there are bigger
differences in terms of Union coverage
um even you know like no other country
in no other country do uh do do workers
have to organize on a firm by firm basis
right you have U more encompassing uh
uhle ctive bargaining agreements you
have a stronger welfare state and so you
know there's a there's a there's a more
solid floor I would say partly because
the reservation wage you just can't pay
people you know two cents in order to to
to perform uh to perform certain certain
tasks where the the floor in the United
States so far at least has been just
much lower but I absolutely take your
point and you know I don't mean to say
that Europe hasn't developed a a very
vibrant consumer culture I also see that
you know Discounters have made inroads
in in Europe absolutely um many of them
are actually they they took their
lessons from the United States like
carfor which is the biggest um uh uh
Discounter in um in uh in France was
founded by this guy who had just come
from the United States uh you know
having just freshly completed a a m um
an MBA and and went and opened a a car 4
um you also have hard Discounters in
countries like Germany and that have
spread um so hard especially in the in
the in the um uh in the food sector so
Aldi Leal these are these so-called hard
Discounters that are just really low low
prices also virtually no Staffing I mean
Trader Joe's actually belongs to was
bought by Aldi so you know if you were
shopping at Trader Joe's that's actually
a an Aldi um extension of Aldi um so I
absolutely think that that's that's
definitely going on so far it has been
in certain sectors much more you know
much more intense than in other sectors
I would say in the grocery sector it's
been especially intense um what maybe is
different about the US is that it's so
it's so spread across all uh across all
um all all product categories so to
speak
um question
anybody students Professor
so yeah so I found this very fascinating
I just wonder if there isn't a missing
piece in the sort
of that goes the uniqueness of the
Amazon mod business model which is my
reading the history is sort of the the
big box stores the Walmarts and the Seas
and the
W worths they put out neighborhood
stores and they also curtailed a lot of
small manufacturing and small services
so you know the neighborhood hardware
store would also fix people's shoes and
cut Keys all of that stuff went to the
Walmarts and so on and Amazon is putting
the big box stores out of business right
I mean it's the Toys R Us it's the Seas
that those are are the people that are
being shut down by
Amazon because they are strictly
retail and um and you see it where they
go Global as well so if you look at like
India where Walmart tried to go into
India they ran into a lot of opposition
from very
small
um you know suppliers
and suppliers of retail services in
manufacturing Amazon is is a huge
success in India very quickly because
they're almost like you know eBay that I
mean all these little suppliers can just
sell on Amazon and so it does seem to me
it's it's it's it's a different maybe
this is just yet another stage or
something but it does seem like there
was this piece not there in your talk so
why don't you have to say about that
yeah so I I should have talked more
about bought Amazon since it was so
prominent in the
title um so I that's that's the piece
that I everybody I think thought knows
but um but in but in fact to link it up
is is is is important first of all just
Walmart also famously flamed out of
German of the German market and partly
on the because of Labor uh they they
couldn't get um uh um they weren't
cooperating with labor and labor wasn't
going to cooperate with them um yeah so
the Walmart I mean Amazon is the next
phase of this so to speak um and there
one of the things that I try to point
out is that there's a way in which you
know people think that Amazon is like
this whole new phenomenon and there are
certain ways in which Amazon what Amazon
is doing is is totally different from
these previous big box uh stores like
big box stores they're big but
ultimately the the selection is limited
to the amount of shelf space that they
have Amazon has no has no such
boundaries right that's one thing the
second thing is that no Walkin and no
Walkin well that's the other thing it
makes it makes purchasing frictionless
it's totally frictionless especially if
you if you get your get your your your
product in the buy box then literally if
you press the button then the the
product is on the way um it also is very
distinctive in the sense that you know
in order to get into these big box
stores your product already has to be
popular right you can't get space on an
Amazon shelf unless you already have a
following and and and um whereas in
Amazon it's it's sort of what they call
longtail uh uh retailing it's like they
can sell even the most obscure things
the most Niche product that only one
person wants um they can you know sell
used things right alongside uh along new
new things so there is the in all those
ways there's something really quite new
about Amazon but what I also am trying
to emphasize in this in this in this
book really is that there's so much of
this strategy that really draws on a
very old Playbook um both an old
playbook in terms of the business
strategy thin you know low low margins
thin you know sort of high volume uh
high volume sales and also the political
um Playbook that you know the way that
they Rose to dominance and so what I
didn't tell here but what you know is
definitely worth telling and is talked
about in the in the book is how how
Amazon itself used regulatory Arbitrage
in order to sort of grow to scale so
like Walmart grew very methodically you
know they he found Sam Walton founded a
store here and then he would you know
Circle that store with a few others and
kind of build out from there the Amazon
model was completely different it was
much closer to Amazon you know just
scale up as fast as possible you know
blanket the country uh and a profitless
growth for for a long time um but a lot
of it is really the old play book it's
like labor you know labor law um uh
violations low wages um a lot of
temporary uh contract workers um you
know a lot of regulatory Arbitrage in
the early years one of Amazon's huge
advantages was that they you know got
around state tax laws by locating in
countries that had or in States that had
low taxes and then shipping to to to
places that had higher taxes I mean the
Supreme Court finally
uh closed that loophole but sort of like
the story that I'm telling you know it
was it was way later by that time Amazon
had grown to scale and by that time they
had ail you know a lot of a lot of
people who had come to organize their
their shopping habits around this around
this retailer so I do want to say that
there are something that there that
Amazon is not something out of brand new
and the technology is interesting and
everything but a lot of a lot of what
they're doing is really kind of goes
back to um old strategies and I mean the
you know like Sears back in the day they
had the high-tech warehouses and what
was high-tech at that time well it was
pneumatic tubes that sent you know
messages around the uh around the
factory and now it's just uh now it's
robots and uh and Pickers um and so I
want to kind of play around with the
simil with the the the Strand that
really you know how we got to this to
this kind of Crescendo of of Amazon and
who knows if Amazon will is the last you
know chapter in the
story yeah so um thank you for coming um
really engaged in talk and excited to
read the book um but I was really um
interested in this point about retailers
exploiting public infrastructure for
private gains um and specifically um two
questions one pertaining to what aspects
about the US um made these large
retailers able to exploit like USPS
Services
um like more so than uh retailers in
other countries is it's just like a a
consequence of like us being a much
larger country with like a more greater
proportion of the population being plal
and then secondly how in the internet
age specifically are retailers
continuing to exploit this public
infrastructure for their own personal
gain oh great great questions um so B so
take the USP the Postal Service um uh
question first so these cooperatives
that I was talking about in Europe they
often also had Credit Unions attached to
them and those Credit Unions were a
source of of capital also to grow the to
grow the co-ops credit unions in this
country were basically boxed out um
until 1921 was the first time you got
any Credit Union at the state level and
it was in Massachusetts um and they were
boxed out by by State uh Bankers state
level Bankers who didn't want the
competition and so the US postal system
was kind of became uh you know it didn't
wasn't designed for that purpose but
that was going to sort of serve the same
function um as um as uh as the
cooperatives would have had um already
kind of inhouse at that time and how do
they continue to exploit public
infrastructure I would say a couple of
uh a lot of ways um one is just this
dependence on snap on food stamps and
SNAP benefits and the dependence on on
uh public um public social social
benefits right that underwrites uh a a
low wage uh a low-wage economy you don't
have to pay workers if they you know you
don't have to provide um uh benefits if
you're the it sort of lowers the floor
um and the and those those low wages are
in effect subsidized by um by um um by
uh by by public social benefits and the
other way is you know like just the
infrastructure of the of the um you know
the entire infrastructure like Walmart
for example depends enormously on on you
know Trucking right and they were huge
beneficiaries of the deregulation of
trucking again it was something that
they didn't cause uh but they certainly
promoted the the the deregulation of
trucking which used to be a very
unionized um a unionized uh sector uh
and that over time became uh completely
deregulated uh such that the the the
salaries of truckers are now really
basically subsistence wage um salaries
and so you know the the public
infrastructure you know Walmart depends
entirely on the uh on the highways and
these truckers that are delivering all
these Goods or independent contractors
who are who are dependent on uh you know
sort of these government progr programs
to to support their families so I those
are just a few of the a few of the
ways um so I haven't uh I haven't
chopped on Amazon since 2017 when I when
I read the com speaks and I I agree that
consumer choice is not the way out of it
this problem um but I was wondering when
you were talking about kind to
Solutions it seems to
me part of the thought and the talk is
that there's a difference between
cooperation and concentration in
antitrust regulation that might be
relevant um
which I guess I just know American anti
trust law is a kind of foreign
distinction to me and I'm was trying to
wrap my head around it and it seems to
me one way that I might understand it is
that price competition is maybe not what
we want in a market so much as quality
competition and Innovation competition
which is why it's okay for a bunch of
small producers to get together to maybe
keep prices higher than they would
otherwise be but they're going to
compete on other ways I suspect that is
maybe not a a distortion of the way that
you would think it but I guess I'm
curious just largely how do you think
about um
differentiating cooperation and
concentration and is there some kind of
do we need to stop thinking about prices
in the economy as a way of measuring
whether we're doing things better or
building a better economy so that's a
great question it's a complicated
question but um the short short answer
is um prices yeah shouldn't be the only
metric because when you think about
consumer welfare you could even think
about you know Innovation quality Etc
and these are all things that are um
that are valued differently in other
countries I will say and I have a paper
on this if you want to if you want more
but you know there is a there is a
really important difference between
there's anti trust breaks out into two
things just crudely um that are pretty
distinct uh one is like H you know what
is what is the attitude toward um s
toward vertical concentration or mergers
and things like that and vertical
dominance or the do the ability of uh
big powerful companies to dominate um
more you know sort of those players that
are reliant on them and then there's
horizontal uh uh um uh
coordination in general and this I'm
going to sort of say this very crudely
but there's it's more complicated in
that in general American antitrust has
always been extremely um strict against
any form of horizontal coordination
that's where Europe has always been
different and it remains different
despite the fact that um European
antitrust has evolved a little bit in
the direction of the US on on many forms
many forms of coordination among
non-dominant players are seen as
competition
enhancing rather than per se illegal
okay um vertical I mean the US has
always been kind of forbid in on
vertical restraints right um and so now
all of the attention or a lot of the
attention in in sort of revising
antitrust law in this country I think is
is it's good be but it focuses almost
exclusively on the issue of abuse of
dominance and I think that's absolutely
a half of the picture but the other half
of the picture would be to talk about
greater forbearance uh Visa um in terms
of coordination among non-dominant
players lers because I think that is
actually really important unless you
think that the government can do all of
this on its own um I really think that
the growing counterveiling
forces I is really quite crucial to kind
of sustaining this uh sustaining
competition over over the longer run so
but there's more to be said thank you so
much for this very inting lecture andone
[Applause]
for
[Music]